hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for honor again and
we have a surprise event to talk about
today it's the anniversary of four
honors starting tomorrow so we have a
new event that's gonna go along with it
and celebrate the anniversary with a lot
of other things as well so as always
like the video if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being the balance changes they hear
updates the Pats notes and the leaks if
you want to be kept up today with
everything happening within the world of
foreigner I never miss out one enough
they definitely stay subscribe to the
channel and with that let's get started
with today's video so like I said if
February 14th is tomorrow aka the
anniversary of for honor spent four
years for very long years of this game
and in celebration of that we have the
honor games we got music Commander's
effects a shitload of killing as well
the new content of the reek will quick
though is going to be a free roam emote
we're gonna have four of them it's gonna
be the bards loot the bards flute the
bars harp and the bards horn which is
the musical emotes that we saw in the
trailer cut like last week so now
they're coming into the game very very
quickly on top of that though like I
said this is gonna be for all heroes and
I'm assuming they're going to be
individual so we will have to get these
individually I don't think you can
purchase the entire thing all four of
them together so you will have to get
them individual if you want it's gonna
be a little costly on steel but they're
still really cool and they're definitely
worth it to grab
[Music]
there's also a new a little heart effect
as well for that special someone in your
life definitely go be sure to pick these
up when you get the chance to because it
is live currently right now we're gonna
be getting into more information on the
event in a second but we do have to talk
about the testing grounds first so in
terms of the testing ground results the
attacking and defending felt a lot more
fair and in terms of either losing lives
or draining the Rams health the breech
testing ground was also a lot faster
than usual breach modes which a lot of
people seem to enjoy and as for the Rams
speed and the Guardian buff people
weren't big on it they didn't really
think it changed much or maybe it was a
bit too much so they're not going to be
adding that but they will monitor that
for the future and as for single pick
that will not be making it into breech
testing ground so quick little updates
the attacking and defending stuff with
the tickets not being a thing in the
very couple phases those will exist but
the breach testing ground will actually
have a title update and it's going to
have a release of March 12th so testing
grounds will be added to the game and
breach will forever be changed on March
12th
speaking of testing grounds as well
there's going to be a new one up and
coming very soon and it's going to be
about the fight system improvement not
the fighting in general like balance but
fight system improvement art of combat
stuff like that we got back in season 5
so that's the way that I'm thinking of
this and and for all the people that are
asking no nothing yet on the Centurion
rubric at the moment they stated that
this one will not have the sentry work
so we're gonna have to wait a little
longer to hopefully maybe get some info
on the rework now on to the part that
you mostly care about the honor games
this is going to be going on from
February 13th to February 27th which is
today until the next two weeks so
basically in terms of a story this is to
celebrate the truce of why Verndale
which is the lore of the season and all
the faction leaders decided to be a good
idea to send their greatest warriors to
fight and compete against one another in
a nice little ceremony there's an arcade
quest that follows this event as well
and you can challenge the leaders of why
Verndale which are the characters in the
main menu when you log on for the season
you can challenge them and in arcade
match and there's also going to be a new
game mode which is called carousel of
fire which is a little slight twist to
care
sell of death a very intense 4v4 mode
that we had back in the day it's still
the very intense 4v4 mode that we know
and love but there's going to be fire in
the middle and attack buffs on the
corners that will also be lit on fire
it's the same thing as carousel of death
with the like the prerequisites of
having to kill everybody on the enemy
team to win and if you played those game
oh do you understand how that works and
it will be being played on the samurai
duel map so extremely close quarters
everywhere you go for the map in general
though this has to be one of my favorite
looking updates to a map I've seen in
this game ever there's minions
commanders the official faction leaders
up at the top lanterns of lights and
fireworks the minions also make noise to
make it seem like it's actually a map
and it's alive and stuff those confetti
on the floor there's a band playing in
the corner and a minions are also
dressed up from past events like the
samurai ninja outfit that you'll be
seeing and also the default minions that
of course got changed with this recent
update there's also loads of posters of
fan art from the community they're going
to be being changed on a weekly basis
first week we're gonna be seeing English
butters Barry the homie fragment and me
and ink eye with next week is gonna be
the boy Titletown reloj coordinator eric
and she's our for next week
these are some absolutely phenomenal
pieces of artwork and I'm actually
really excited that they're actually
adding this to the map and that these
will be changing every week to kind of
give that recognition to the fan artists
that you know put a lot of time and
effort into their artwork on top of that
there's also going to be a wall on
opposite sides of the game displaying
your emblems on the wall for each team
on the map which is really cool this is
easily in the top three of events and I
haven't even loaded up the game yet just
because it has everyone coming together
in a nice cheery mood having a good time
it feels alive in the map and I just
honestly love it week two of the event
according to the developers will have
some juicy stuff in game they quote they
say maybe it's game mode related or
maybe it's not but either way I'll have
to keep you guys up to date on that
regardless of what it happens to be but
we're not done yet
we have cosmetics to talk about as well
there's gonna be community orders and
then we'll be getting some steel and
event emblems just for playing the new
game mode there's also going to be a new
effect called the beacon of peace for
emotes execution end
which is going to be lootable the battle
outfit is called warrior of peace in a
blue coloring which is also lootable and
the new ornament called jewel of peace
which is also lootable and in his
faction base so it's different depending
on the faction you purchase it for and
like I said these are glued Abul so all
you have to do is just play the game
mode and hope that you get the stuff for
your specific character that you want
and you're all good but yeah that's the
quick recap of everything happening
within the next couple weeks super super
excited to be able to see how this plays
out in game and how this is going to
work and everything else like that so
definitely let me know in the comments
below you guys think of the event so far
from just a first impression or if
you've already played it by now and
definite let me know what you think I
think it's easily one of my top three
look I've stated but obviously I haven't
even played it yet maybe it's trash but
I doubt it this map looks phenomenal by
the way let me know what you guys think
about this stuff in the comments below
like the video if you do enjoy subscribe
if you're new or that guys take care
have a great astir day peace out enjoy
the event and goodbye
[Music]